We are continuing our
discussion of fault-tolerance
and atomicity.
And sort of teaching
these lectures
makes me feel, in the beginning,
like those TV shows where
they always, before
a new episode,
tell you everything that
happened so far in the season.
So we will do the same thing.
The story so far here is that
in order to deal with failures,
we came up with this idea
of making modules have
this property of atomicity,
which actually has
two aspects to it, one of which
is an all or nothing aspect,
which we call recoverability,
and the other is a way
to coordinate multiple
concurrent activities so you
get this illusion that they are
all separate from each other.
And we call that isolation.
And the basic rule here for
achieving recoverability
was we repeatedly
applied this one rule
that we called the "Golden Rule
of Recoverability" which is
to never modify the only copy.
And we used that
rule to build up
this idea of recoverable
sector and we
used that idea of
recoverable sector
to come up with two schemes
for achieving recoverability,
one using version
histories where
you had a special case
of this "Never Modify
the Only Copy Rule" which
was never modify anything.
So, for any given
variable, you must
create lots and lots of
versions never updating
anything in place.
And then we decided
that it is inefficient,
so we came up with a different
way of achieving recoverability
using logging.
Then for isolation,
we did this last time
where we talked
about serializability
where the goal was to allow the
steps of the different actions
to run in such a way that
the result is as if they
ran in some serial order.
And we talked about a
way of achieving that
with cell storage.
In particular, we talked about
using locks as an abstraction,
as a programming primitive
to achieve isolation.
And, in particular, the
key idea that we saw here
was that serializability
implied that there
were no cycles in this data
structure called the action
graph.
And, as long as you
could argue that
for a given method of locking,
as long as you could argue
that the resulting action
graph had no cycles,
you were guaranteed
serializability.
And, therefore, the
scheme provided isolation.
And, in particular, a scheme
we looked at near the end
was two-phase locking.
Where the idea is that you never
acquire a lock for any item
if you have done a
release of any other lock
in the atomic action so far.
And that's the reason why
this is called two-phase
locking because if you
look at the two phases
being a lock acquisition phase
where the only thing that
is happening is locks
are being acquired
and nothing is being released
so the number of locks
is strictly
increasing with time.
And then there is
a certain point
of the action after which
you can only release locks.
And you cannot acquire a lock
the moment you have released
any given lock.
And the way we argued this
protocol achieved isolation was
to consider the
action graph resulting
from some execution
of two-phase locking
and argued that if there was a
cycle in that resulting action
graph then two-phase
locking gets violated.
And, therefore,
two-phase locking
provides an action graph
which does not have cycles
and, therefore, achieves
serializability.
Two-phase locking is fine
and is a really good idea
if you're into using locks.
It has the property that you
do not actually need to know,
the action does not need to
know at the beginning which
data items it is going to
access which means that all you
need to do is to make sure that
you do not release anything
until everything
has been acquired.
But you do not have to
know which ones to acquire
before the start of the action.
You just have to keep
acquiring sort of on demand
until typically you get
to the commit point.
And once you commit you
can release the locks.
Now, in theory you can release
a lock at any given time
once you are sure that you are
not going to acquire anymore
locks, but that
theoretical approach only
works if you are
guaranteed that there
will be no aborts happening.
Now, in general, you cannot know
beforehand when an action might
abort.
I mean the system
might decide to abort
an action for a
variety of reasons,
and we will see
some reasons today.
In practice, what
ends up happening
is that when you abort
you have to go back
and look through the log
and undo the actions,
run the undo steps
associated with steps
that happened in the action.
Which means that because
the undo goes ahead
into cell storage and uninstalls
whatever changes were made,
it better be the case that when
abort starts undoing things,
it better be the case that
the cell storage items that
are being undone have locks
owned by this action that
is doing the undo.
What this means is that if you
have a set of statements here
that are doing read of x and a
write of y and things like that
and then you have commit here --
But this is the last
point in time at which
you are reading and writing.
And after that you are doing
some computation here not
involving any reads or writes.
The action might abort anywhere
here because the process,
I mean this thread
might be terminated
and the action
will have to abort.
What that means is that a
release for a data item that
is required by abort in
order to undo the state
changes that have
been made, that lock
had better not be
released before here.
Because if the lock
got released here then
some other action could
have acquired the lock
and gone ahead and started
working with the changes made
by this action.
And now it is too late to abort.
Someone else has
already seen the changes
that have been made.
In fact, you cannot be
guaranteed now that later
on you actually can regain the
lock and the results would be
wrong.
So, in fact, the two-phase
locking rule really is that you
cannot release any lock until
all of the locks have been
acquired.
And, moreover, any locks that
are needed in order for abort
to successfully
run had better not
be released until you are
sure that the action won't
abort anymore.
And the only time
you can be sure
that the action
won't abort anymore
is once commit has been done.
What that really means
is that the release
of the locks of all
of the items that
are required for
undoing this action
had better happen
after the commit point.
And, moreover, no
item locks should
be released until all of
the acquires have been done.
Now the reason I've
said this in two parts
is that if you are just
reading a data item,
you actually don't need to
hold onto the lock of that item
in order to do the undo
because all you did was read x.
There is no change that
happened to the variable
x, which means although you
need to acquire the lock of x
in order to read it because
you don't want to have
other people making changes to
it while you are reading it,
you don't actually need to hold
onto the lock of x in order
to do the undo because
you are not actually
writing x during the undo step.
So that's the amendment to
the two-phase locking rule.
Things that you need in
order to do undos for
should only be
released after you
are sure that no aborts
will be done, which
means after the commit point.
This way of doing
two-phase locking
is actually a
pretty good scheme.
And it turns out
that, in many ways,
it is the most efficient
and most general method.
What that means is that there
might be special cases where
other ways of other protocols
for doing locks of objects
perform better under
certain special cases
compared to two-phase
locking, but if you've
bought into using locks in
order to do concurrency control
and you don't know very
much about the nature
of the actions involved
then two-phase locking
is quite efficient.
I mean there are variants
of two-phase locking
but, by and large, this
idea, it's very hard
to do much better than this
in a very general sense
if you're using locking for
doing concurrency control.
But there are a set of problems.
It's not two-phase locking, as
we have described it so far,
completely solves the
problem of insuring
that actions perform well.
And a particular
problem that happens
any time you use locks
like here is deadlocks.
And we have actually
seen deadlocks
before in an
earlier chapter when
we talked about
synchronization of threads,
and it is exactly
the same problem.
And the way you deal with it
pretty much is almost the same.
What is the problem here?
Well, what could happen
is that one action does
read x and write y and the other
action does read y and write x.
And now you intersperse
the acquires and releases
so you do an acquire of
lx here and maybe you
do an acquire of ly here and
here you do an acquire of ly
and you do an acquire of lx.
And what could happen is that
once you get to this stage
where this action has come this
far and is about to run this
and this other action
has come up to here,
now you are stuck
because this action has
to wait until that is
released and this action has
to wait until that is released
and neither can make progress.
So there are a few different
ways of dealing with it.
And the simplest way and
the way that turns out
to be one that is often
used in practice both
because it is simple and
because once you implement
the technique you don't
have to do very much else
is to just set
timers on actions.
So it's just to timeout.
And if you notice that
for a period of time
an action has not
made any progress
then have a timeout that is
associated with the action.
And if the action
itself notices that it
hasn't made any progress,
perhaps in another thread,
then just go ahead
and abort this thread.
Now, it is perfectly
OK to abort.
And, in this particular
case, aborting
either of these
actions is enough
and the other will make
progress and then you are done.
And then the action that
got aborted can retry.
So the first solution
is to just use a timer.
And there is a school
of thought that
believes that in
practice deadlocks
should not be very common.
And the reason is that
deadlocks occur if there is,
you know, there has to be
a contention for resources
and there has to be contention
for multiple threads
for the same resources.
And it has to be more
than one resource,
because if you just have one
resource you cannot really get
a deadlock which means that you
are sort of running multiple
actions that are contending for
a number of different shared
objects.
And what that
suggests is if there
is a high degree of concurrency
like that and shared contention
then it may be hard for you
to get high performance.
A lot of people think
that the right way
to be designing
applications is to try
hard to insure that the degree
of sharing between objects
is actually quite small.
For example, rather
than set up a lock
on an entire big
database table, you
might set up locks at
final granularities.
And if you set up locks
at final granularities
the chances of multiple
actions wanting to gain access
to the same exact
fine-grained entry in a table
might be small.
And in that situation,
given that the chances
of a deadlock
occurring are rare,
timing out every once in a
while and aborting an action
is not going to be catastrophic.
It's OK.
It is a rare event.
So rather than spend a
whole lot of complexity
dealing with that
rare event, just
go ahead and let
something abort.
Let an action that hasn't
made any progress abort.
Moreover, these
timers are necessary
anyway because an
action might end up
getting stuck in
an infinite loop
or it might end up getting
stuck in a situation where
it is not really waiting for a
lock there is just a bug in it.
There is a problem with
it, it is not really
making any progress and maybe
it is consuming resources
and no one else
can make progress.
So the system anyway needs a
way to abort those actions.
And it needs a timeout
mechanism anyway.
So why not just use
that same mechanism
to deal with deadlocks as well.
Probably somewhat a minority,
but some other people
believe that deadlocks
might happen.
And, when they do
happen, perhaps
because the granularity
of locking in your system
is not fine-grained then you
do not want to get stuck.
And you want to
optimize, at least
you want to do reasonably
well rather than
waiting for some
long timeout period
before aborting an action.
And people who believe that
build a data structured called
the "Waits-For Graph".
And the best way
to understand this
is imagine you have a database
system that supports isolation
and any time you want
to acquire a lock you
send a message to this
entity in the database system
called lock manager
asking to acquire a lock.
And any time you release
it you do the same thing.
What that lock manager
can do, for each lock
it can keep track of which
actions running concurrently
has acquired that lock and which
action is waiting for a lock.
And what you can do now is build
up a graph of actions and locks
and look to see whether there
is some kind of cycle where you
have action A waiting
for lock B and lock
B is being held by action C and
action C is waiting for lock D
and lock D is being
held by action A.
When you have a
cycle in this graph
then you know that
you have a deadlock
and none of those actions
can make progress so go ahead
and kill one.
And you can be
sophisticated about deciding
which one to kill.
You might kill the
one, for example,
that has been waiting the
shortest amount of time
because the others have been
waiting longer so they might
make progress, or you might
have other policies for deciding
which ones to kill.
In practice, both these
systems are used sometimes
by the same system
combining these ideas.
For example, if you look at
like an Oracle database system,
it uses primarily timers.
At least from what
I could tell, it
does not seem to
have any mechanisms
for really doing this
check of a Waits-For graph.
It just uses timers.
And one of the oldest
transaction processing systems
was a system called
CICS from IBM
which also basically
used timers,
but there are other systems.
For instance, IBM has this
system called DB2 and Microsoft
Sequence server that both use
this Waits-For data structure.
And, in fact,
Microsoft's system seems
to have a hundred thousand
different knobs for deciding
how to turn off deadlocks,
including the ability
to set various priorities
on different actions that
might be running.
And it is not actually apparent
that those knobs actually
are usual for anything
or how you set them
but that they have a lot of
things that you could set.
Sounds familiar.
Now, you can combine these two.
And I think certain products
combine these two ideas.
One decision you have to
make is to decide when
to check this Waits-For graph.
And an aggressive way of
doing it is the moment anybody
does an acquire or
anybody does a release,
in particular an acquire, you
update your lock manager's data
structure and immediately look
to see if you have a cycle.
Of course that takes
time and effort.
You might decide not to
both but rather periodically
look for cycles in
this Waits-For graph
when a timer fires, so
every three seconds go ahead
and look for cycles.
So you might combine these ideas
in a bunch of different ways.
Now, if you recall from
several lectures ago,
another way of
dealing with deadlock
is to order all of the
locks that an action might
be able to acquire
in a particular order
and insure that
all of the actions
acquire the locks in
exactly the same order.
And that will insure there
are no cycles because you have
to go in the same order,
but that idea requires
you to know beforehand
which data items
you wish to gain access to.
And that's often not possible
in many systems in which you
care about isolations.
So that's usually not adopted
at least in any database system.
OK, so we talked
about deadlocks.
We talked about when you can
release a lock that you acquire
in order to abort because you
cannot release it typically,
in reality, until the
commit point is done.
The last issue we
need to talk about
is an interaction
between logs and locks.
And this interaction
has to do with,
so we already saw what
happens when you abort.
When you abort you need
to undo so you better
make sure that to
do the undo you
have the locks for
those cell items.
You don't have to abort
but suppose you crash.
Suppose the system
crashes and recovers.
At that point, when
it recovers, it
is going to run a
recovery procedure which
has some combination
of redoing the winners
and undoing the losers.
Now, when it's undoing
things and redoing things
it needs access to
items in the cell store.
And we've already seen
when the system is normally
running, in order to change
items in your cell store
you need to gain
access to locks.
The question now is
during crash recovery
when the system is running
this redo undo thing,
where do you get these
locks from and do you need
to gain access to the locks?
Now, in general, the
answer to the question
might be that you need
to be very careful
and perhaps need
access to the locks
when you're running recovery.
But there is one simplification
that systems typically
make that eliminates
that requirement.
And that simplification is
that during crash recovery
you don't really allow new
actions to run on your system.
So when a system crashes
and it is recovering,
do not allow new actions to
run until recovery is complete.
And only then do you
start new actions.
What this means is
now we just have
to worry about insuring
isolation clearly
during recovery without
having new actions coming
in and muddling things up.
The question really
to think about
is whether before the
crash, because the log is
the only thing you
have in order to do
recover, whether in
the log you actually
need to keep track
of which locks
were being held when the
system was running just fine.
And if it turns out
that the log has
to encode in it the locks
that were being held,
it could be quite complicated
and a little bit messy.
But if you think about
it, the nice thing
is that we don't actually have
to encode the locks at all,
store the locks at all.
The locks can be completely
involved in the storage.
And that is because
when you start off,
when you have a log which
has various redo items
and undo items, in any
element of the log,
let's say an item x has been
updated in that log entry.
Then you know for
sure that at the time
this log entry was
written, the action
that was making this update
did hold onto this lock
and that this change
being made here
that got written to the log
was, in fact, isolated assuming
the locking protocol
was correct,
was, in fact, isolated from
everything else concurrently
that was going on.
And so, although the
locks are not explicit,
the log encodes in it the actual
serial order, some serial order
of execution that did provide
isolation before the crash.
Therefore, if you just blindly
go back through the log
and make those changes
in sequential order
then you are assured
that the changes you make
are, in fact, going to be
isolated from one another.
So you do not
actually have to worry
about storing the locks
before the crash into the log,
and that makes
life quite simple.
That wraps up the discussion of
atomicity and, in particular,
isolations.
For the rest of
today and next time
we are going to be talking
about some uses of atomicity.
And the plan is the following.
The plan is the first
application of atomicity which
actually is the umbrella
for a number of things
we are going to be looking
at is a transaction.
And a transaction is
defined as an atomic action
that has a few other
properties that it holds.
And the first property
is consistency
and the second
property is durability.
And the second thing we
are going to look at,
next lecture
actually, is atomicity
when you have a
distributed system.
It is using atomicity
on one computer
to build out a system
that provides atomicity
in a distributed system.
So we will talk about
consistency the rest of today
and the recitation
for tomorrow looks
at a paper for reconciling
replicas, which
is a particular
aspect of consistency.
And then next
lecture next week we
will talk about
multi-site atomicity.
And the recitation next week
we will talk about durability.
And once we do all of
that, that kind of wraps up
this fault-tolerance
part of 6.033.
Let me first talk a little
bit about transactions.
Transaction is an
atomic action that
has two other properties
associated with it.
And people in the literature
often, in collegial terms,
refer to transactions
as having a property
called the ACID
property where ACID
stands for atomicity,
consistency, isolation
and durability.
And you will see this
term a great deal
in the literature and people
will use this all the time.
And, for various
reasons, the way
we have done things in this
class, some of these terms
are used in slightly different
ways from the ACID term.
When most people, at least
in distributed systems
and database systems, use the
word atomicity, what they mean
is what we meant
by recoverability.
So it is all or nothing.
When they use the letter
I here for isolation,
they mean exactly the same
thing here that we did.
And consistency and
durability unfortunately
are going to mean
the exact same thing.
But really the
point to notice is
that these two properties,
atomicity and isolation
are things that are
independent of an application.
They just are properties
of atomic actions
that an atomic action
can be recoverable
and can be isolated.
And you do not have to worry
about what the application is.
It could be an application
in database systems.
It could be something
in a processor
where you are trying to
provide recoverability
or isolation for instructions.
These are properties
that are, in some sense,
somewhat more fundamental
and lower layer
properties than these
other two properties.
What consistency
means is the property
of an atomic action that is some
application-specific invariant.
Consistency of a
transaction says
that if you have
a transaction that
commits then some set of
consistency invariants
must hold.
I will describe some
examples of what this means.
Consistent just
says that there is
some application-specific
invariants that must hold.
And durability says that if
a transaction commits then
the state changes
that it has made,
that the data items
that it has changed
has to last for
some period of time.
And the period of time
that they have to last for
is defined by the application.
And there are many examples.
A simple example
of durability might
be that the changes
made by an atomic action
just have to last until
the entire thread finishes.
And, at the other
extreme, you could
get into semantics
of durability which
say that the changes
made by an atomic action
have to last for three
years or for five years
or for forever which is a
really hard thing to solve.
But you might define
semantics that relates
to the permanence of data.
For how long do you
want the changes
that you made to
last and be visible
to other atomic actions?
There are two cases
for consistency
that we need to talk about.
The first one is consistency
in a centralized system.
An example of this, and the
most common example of this
is in database systems
that support transaction
where you might have rules
that are also called integrity
rules for deciding whether
you are allowing a transaction
to commit or not.
Let me give you a couple
of examples of this.
Let's say that you have
a type of database system
as a relational database
system where all of the data
is stored in tables.
For example, you might have
a table storing a student
ID, a student name and
let's say the department
that the student belongs to.
And let's say the
departments have IDs.
And you might have another
table in your system
that stores a department
ID and a department name.
Now, you might
have a transaction
that makes updates to entries
in this table, you know,
one or more rows in this table
could actually make updates
to just specific
cells of this table.
It could add a new
student ID, add a name
and add some department ID.
Now, the kind of constraint
we are worried about,
the kind of invariants
we are worried about
are things where the person
who has designed this database
might say that you are not
allowed to add a department
ID that is nonexistent.
And what that means is that
there are these two tables.
And you should not
allow any transaction
to write the department ID which
is not already in this table.
So if 43 might be in this table
and 25 might be on this table,
but a number that is not in this
table should not be added here.
And so the transaction
processing system might decide,
will, in fact, not
allow this transaction
to commit if it is
writing a value that
is not in this other table.
And, for those familiar with
databases, relation databases,
there are these two
tables called T1 and T2.
This might be a primary key.
Department ID might
be a primary key
of T2 defined as what is called
a foreign key in T1, which
means that you are not actually
allowed to add something
to a foreign key if
it is not already
in the other table where that
same column is a primary key.
So there are rules like this
in most relational database
systems and there are
a variety of rules
like this that all have to do
with maintaining the integrity
of the data that you add here.
Now, this has nothing
to do with isolation.
It has to do with atomicity
because these rules are
typically checked
at the commit point,
because until then
anything could happen.
So, right before
you commit, there
are these invariants
on the data that
are application-specific
that you need to check.
But it has nothing
to do with locks.
It has nothing to
do with anything.
It sort of presumes
atomicity, and after that it
checks these
application-specific rules.
And you can get
quite sophisticated.
Some of these things about
primary keys and secondary keys
are things that are
checked by most transaction
processing systems, but you
could get quite sophisticated
about these rules.
For example, you
could have rules.
Let's say you have
a database storing
employees and their salaries.
You could have rules that
say any time an employee gets
a raise then everybody
else in the same peer group
also gets some kind of raise.
And so you wouldn't
allow any transaction
to commit that did not insure
that invariant to hold.
And checking these things
could be quite difficult,
and most systems do not
actually do a really good job
of checking these things.
The sets of rules they
allow you to write
is quite limited because
checking it is quite hard,
because when you are trying
to commit a transaction now
you might have to check
a large number of rules.
And some of them could be both
time-consuming and complicated.
But the main point here
is that these rules
are application-specific.
And that is what defines
consistency of the data
that you have.
The more interesting
case for consistency
and the thing that
is going to occupy us
for the rest of
today and tomorrow
is consistency in
distributed systems.
In particular,
when the same data
gets distributed, typically
for fault-tolerance
and for availability, to
insure that the data is
available at
different locations,
you end up with
consistency problems.
And we have already seen
a few examples of this.
One example of this is in
the "Domain Name System"
which maintains mapping between
domain names and IP addresses.
And, if you remember, in
order to achieve availability
and good performance,
these mappings
between DNS names and
IP addresses where
cached essentially on demand.
Whenever a name
server on the Internet
made an access to
that name it address
cached the mapping results.
And so now you
have to worry about
whether the data that is cached
somewhere out on the Internet
is, in fact, the correct
data where correct is defined
as the data that is being
maintained by the primary name
server.
And if you think about
DNS did, it actually
used a mechanism
of expiration times
to keep this cache consistent.
And what that means
is that the only time
you are guaranteed that
the data in a cache
is, in fact, the data that
is stored at the primary name
server for that name is when
this expiration time finishes.
And the first access
after the expiration time
requires the name server to go
to the original primary name
server and do a
look up of the name.
So the rest of the time you
cannot actually be guaranteed
that the data is consistent.
And, in other words,
you are not getting
what is considered
strong consistency.
What is strong consistency?
One way to define
the semantics of what
it means for data to be
consistent in a distributed
system is it is sort of a
natural definition which
is to see that any time
you do a read anywhere,
any node does a
read of some data,
read returns the result
of the late write.
That is one notion
of consistency.
And a system provides
strong consistency
if you can insure that
every read returns
the result of the last write
that was done on the data.
And this is really
hard to provide
because what it typically means
is that the data is widely
replicated or cached.
Any time anybody
changes the data
you have to make sure that all
of the copies get that change.
And, even if you work really
hard to invalidate all
the entries and
make changes to it,
there are these small windows
of vulnerability where --
In fact, in DNS, for example,
even the first access
that you make the server
after the expiration time
may not guaranty that
when the response returns,
the response is, in
fact, the newest response
because the primary name
server could send a response.
And, while it is coming back to
the person who made the query,
the data could get changed
at the primary name server
so it is really hard
to guaranty this,
at all points in time,
in a distributed system.
And it gets much
harder when there
are failures making
certain copies unavailable
or making access to a primary
in the DNS case unavailable.
In practice, in most
systems, the kind
of consistency that people try
to get is eventual consistency
or they try to approximate
strong consistency
in some other way.
And eventually
consistency just --
It is a little bit of a loser
notion, but what it says
is that there might
be periods of time
where things are consistent or
that the system is doing work
in the background to
make sure that all
of the copies of a given data
item are, in fact, the same
and are the result of the
last write to that data.
Again, the notion of
eventual consistency
depends a lot on
the application.
So, really, to specify
this precisely you
have to look at in the
context of the application.
Different applications
you have different notions
of consistency and
eventual consistency.
So we looked at
DNS as an example.
Another example to
look at is something
you might be familiar with
which is "Web caches".
Web caches, for example, your
browser has a cache in it.
And there might be Web
caches located elsewhere
in the network that
capture your requests.
And people use Web
caches to save latency
or to prevent slamming a Web
server that might otherwise
get overloaded.
The semantics here are
usually that you do not just
return stale data.
If the data has changed
on the Web server,
it might be that you
actually want to return
good data to the client.
The way this is normally
done is for the client
or for any cache to first
check with the Web server
to see if the data
has been changed
since the last cached version.
Let's say that the cache
went to the Web server
at 9:00 in the morning and had
to go there because it did not
have the data in the cache.
And it got some data back.
The data has a timestamp on it.
Then the next time somebody
makes a request to the cache,
the cache does not just
return the data immediately.
What the cache usually does
is to go to the Web server
and ask the Web server
if the data has changed
since 9:00 in the morning.
If the data has changed
since 9:00 in the morning
you might retrieve the data.
You would retrieve the
data for the server.
If not then go ahead and
return the data to the client.
This is also called
"If-Modified-Since"
because what you are saying is
the cache is telling the server
send me the data if it has been
modified since the last time I
know the version of
the data that I have.
And a convenient way
to represent that
is as a timestamp.
It's just a version of the data.
So you can see
that this actually
provides a more stronger
consistency semantics than DNS.
Because in DNS the
data could have changed
and your cache just
has outdated data.
But for the application
that DNS is used for
it is perfectly OK for
that to be the case.
Now, in general, in
distributed systems
there is a tradeoff
between the consistency
of data at the different
replicas and availability.
Availability just means
that clients wanting data
should get some
copy of the data.
Now, if the system is strongly
consistent then the copy
of data that you
get is, in fact,
the result of the last write.
But the tradeoff occurs between
availability and consistency
because in many
distributed systems
your networks are not reliable
or nodes themselves are not
reliable and they might fail.
So in the presence of failures,
say network partitions
or failures of
nodes, it turns out
to be really hard to guaranty
both high availability
and strong consistency.
As sort of a trivial
existent example of this,
if you have three
copies of the data
and you were not very careful
about figuring out your
write protocol.
Let's say that your write
protocol was to sort of write
to one version and
then your read protocol
was to just read from
some other version
and for some process
in the background
to transfer the replica
from the first version
that the client wrote to,
to all of the other copies,
then there would be periods
of time of the network
where partitioned you
could end up in a situation
where the version that a
given client is reading
is not actually the last version
of the data that was written.
In fact, if you started thinking
about DP2, Design Project 2,
really, one part of it gets at
how you manage replicated data.
For example, when the utility
that does the archiving
publishes data, one
approach it might take
is to publish the
data that it wants
to archive to all of the copies,
to all of the replica machines.
And the read protocol might
be to read from one of them.
Now, if you insure that
the write protocol finishes
and succeeds only when all
of the replica machines
are updated then you can try
to get at a decent version
of consistency.
But you need to be able to
do that when failures occur.
The network might fail
or nodes might fail,
and you need to figure
out how to do that.
But you might decide that
writing to end copies
and reading from one copy is
difficult or has high overhead
so you might think about ways
of writing to certain subsets,
writing to a subset
of the machines
and reading from a
subset of the machines
to try to see whether
you could come up
with ways to get a consistent
version of the data.
Or you might decide that the
right way to solve the problem
is not to try to achieve
really strong consistency
in all situations but to
relax the kind of consistency
you want and maybe a different
version of semantics.
As long as you are precise
about the semantics
that your system
provides, it might
be a different solution
or reasonable solution
to the problem.
So one interesting
way in which people
achieve reasonable
strong consistency
in tightly coupled distributed
systems, and distributed
systems that are not across the
Internet where a network could
arbitrarily fail, but in
more tightly coupled systems
is in a multiprocessor.
If you have a computer
that has many processors --
And the abstraction here
for this multiprocessor
is that of shared memory.
You actually have memory
sitting outside here,
and these processors
are reading and writing
data to this memory.
The latency to get to
memory and back is high.
So, as you know, processors
have caches on them.
As long as the memory locations
that are being written and read
are not shared between
them these caches
could function just fine.
And when there is an
instruction running
on one of these processors that
wants to access some memory
location, you could just
read and write from the cache
so things would just work out.
The problem arises when there
is a memory location being
read here that
actually was previously
written by this processor.
And, if you read
it here, then you
might get an old
version of the data.
And if you think of just memory
as the basic abstraction,
virtual memory then
this is bad semantics
because your programs wouldn't
function the same way as they
did when you just
had one processor
or when you didn't
have the caches at all
and you just went
directly to memory
from multiple processors.
The question is how do you know
whether the data in a cache
is good or bad?
Now, like in the Web caches
case, checking on every access
whether the data
has changed is not
going to be useful here
because the amount of work
it takes to check something is
about the same as the amount
of work it takes to
read or write something
because you have taken
the latency hit for that.
So that approach is
not going to work.
The solution that is
followed in many systems
is to use two ideas.
The first idea is that
of a "Write-Thru Cache".
What a write-thru
cache says is if there
is a write that happens
here, or store instruction,
the cache gets updated.
But, in addition to the
cache getting updated,
the data also gets
written through
on the bus to the
memory location here.
So that is the first idea,
to use a write-thru cache.
The second is because this
is a bus all of these nodes
can actually snoop
on this bus and see
what activity there is on the
bus because it is a shared bus.
It is a very special kind
of network, as I said.
You cannot apply
this idea in general.
It is a very special
kind of network
where because it is a
bus and nothing fails,
or the assumption
is nothing fails,
everybody can check to see
what is going on on the bus.
And any time there is any
activity on the bus that
corresponds to something that
is stored in any node's cache
you can do two things.
You can actually
invalidate that cache entry
but you can actually also see
what the update is and go ahead
and look at the change
that was being done
and update your cache.
And this idea is sometimes
called a "Snoopy Cache"
because you have
these caches that
are snooping on activity that
is occurring in your system.
And this is one way in which
you can achieve something that
resembles strong consistency.
But it actually turns out,
if you think hard about it,
a precise version of
strong consistency
is really hard to achieve.
In fact, it is very,
very hard to even define
what it means for
any read to see
the result of the last
write because when
you have multiple people
reading and writing things,
when you get down to
the instruction level,
it turns out to be really
hard to even define
the right semantics.
A lot of people are working
on this kind of thing.
But this is a little
bit of a special case
because this kind of
solution applies only
in a very tightly coupled
system where you do not really
have failures and everybody
can listen to everything else.
But it is interesting
to note that there
are cases when
you can achieve it
and that is why
this is interesting.
It is practically useful.
So the main thing
about Design Project 2
that relates to the
consistency discussion
is for you to try to, I mean
at least one part of it,
in case it was not clear from
the description of the project
is for you to think about what
kind of consistency you want
and come up with ways to manage
these different replicas.
We are going to stop here.
Next week we will talk
about multi-site atomicity.
Tomorrow's recitation
is on a system
called Unison which also looks
at consistency when you have
mobile computers that are
trying to synchronize data
with servers.